أنت تعلم أنني يجب أن أسألك أم شاكيرا
ورفض دوا ليبا المشاركة في
كأس العالم هذه بسبب السجلات السيئة
لقطر فيما يتعلق بحقوق الإنسان ومن
الواضح أن الناس يعتقدون أن مالوما ليس
لديك مشكلة مع انتهاك حقوق
الإنسان في هذا البلد  نعم ، لكن
هذا شيء يمكنني حله ، لقد جئت للتو
إلى هنا للاستمتاع بالحياة والاستمتاع بكرة القدم ،
فإن حفلة كرة القدم ليست في
الواقع شيئًا يجب أن
أشارك فيه ، فأنا هنا أستمتع
بموسيقاي واه ، وألعب كرة القدم أيضًا
ولكن يمكنني  أنت تفهم فقط الأشخاص الذين
سيقولون أنهم من خلال
تواجدك هنا أنت
تفهم أنه يجب علي الإجابة على هذا السؤال ،
حسنًا ،
لا ولكني فقط أطالب الناس بأن يسأل الناس ما هي
المشكلة التي
أعنيها  m وقح لماذا أنا وقح maloma
لا أعتقد أنني أعتقد أن هذا
ما يقوله الناس هو سبب تفكير الناس بأنهم
أجنبي